jeudi des extraits alors oui tu danses
est un rappeur marseillais c'est ma tête
de ma mère je suis contente de voir qui
de tout cas c'est mon frère
ça vous avez un nouveau pendentif ouais
c'est une petite menotte ses souvenirs
ferrat très bons souvenirs bon je
termine un cadeau c'est énorme c'est
faire plaisir d'inverser un amour à
magnéto magnétoscope pathé marconi ne
vient pas des fils enfin c'est je te
démerdes après je me retrouvais défilent
comme ça l'a prêté marconi il est le
patron
qu'est ce que tu vas nous faire
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va chanter un
simple des chants de noël
l'accord de noix avec la sig frères tous
cas de noël de père noël de mes couilles
et en date est d'avoir retrouvé faudra
trouver l'interprète original d'accord
si on rajoute les jouets cheyrou qui
jouent alors attention demain mercier
n'a si vous signez pas des horaires est
ce que je vais faire ce soir je me coupe
une je m'accroche au plafond je voulais
direct peuple au plafond s'il vous plaît
le risque de retomber si jamais vous
vous êtes un mec qui ce qui me frappe et
cela paie d'accord les frères tu
appelles tu es tout ce que tu veux mais
alors il va prendre trois débats à
l'univers musique
mais sans la musique fallait
je les trouvais au petit matin doute
plus jamais grossier la cde dans la
cheminée pas besoin de vous faire un
dessin de battements de coeur s'est
arrêté sur le lit j'ai jeté m'en vais
ils se connaissent tous et est la fille
du père noël j'étais le fils du père
souhaite à rêves s'appelait marie noëlle
je m'appelais ce matin c'était la fille
du père noël était le fils du père
fouettard et s'appelait marie noëlle jeu
marc freléchoux maltazard
si vous voulez foncé dans quelque chose
foncier dans le sapin ne me tente pas
alors est ce que vous avez trouvé
dutronc la fille du père noël ouais
ouais
est-ce pas
merci ça c'est bon c'est ce que c'est la
deuxième année s'est trompé si vous avez
entendu vous allez savoir ce qu'est la
deuxième c'est pas grave c'est cadeau
non c'est pas cadeau un attaquant c'est
pas sûr on peut changer attention
indiqué par 3i musique sur la deuxième
frère
les yeux levés vers le ciel les petits
enfants avant de fermer les paupières
soit une dernière bière mais pourquoi tu
descendras du ciel avec des jouets par
milliers
n'oublie pas un petit soulier
alors c'est quoi alors petit papa noël s
et aux marques
le fait qu'un jeune est déjà fait je
sais tu vois c'est vrai que jouer devant
tire pas un truc à faire
vous êtes sûr que ça va marcher de fouet
oui ça m'arrive en alarmer faites ce que
vous voulez vous allez on y va
je vois les gars je reviens je vais voir
autant en emporte le vent fait la
troisième est ce assez pour mes frères
de couleur musique fraîche
ici les chars couverts de neige les gens
ne les connaît qu'on foute le père noël
n'a pas de traîneau le fond de l'air est
si les portes sont toujours ouvertes peu
après dans la maison et pour partager
nos chances on a besoin d'invitation
joyeux noël brisé deux fois deux princes
ce soir mon état là
mais ce soir ce jeune homme a chanté non
joyeux noël était de fort de princes ce
soir on est dans la série ce soir
ensemble va chanter
senna ce n'est pas par long mais alors
là ça ne voulait pas répéter ce soir de
frein ce à quoi nicolas l'accord m était
la couleur est plus rare
et comme les nôtres
enfin
ah ah
quoi
oh
si votre rsa tous petits des tornades
on retrouve tous les matins sur des 17
entre 7h et 9h saint génis